what did you do with your voice do you
put something on your voice or uh
doesn't no nothing they asked that about
Rocket Raccoon too I took major offense
to that then I got to tell you something
I am 100% convinced that they deepen
your voice somehow wow let me tell you
how it's going to be every time that's
it isn't that it yeah every time I watch
Rocket Raccoon I can't wrap my head
around the fact that that's you yeah no
we I mean unless unless they're lying to
me they've not uh augmented it at all
how much prep time do you do with doing
the voice of rock raccoon no no prep I
just go in there and um start really
yeah they they describe the scene to you
you've read the script I've read the
script I go in there the first time we
do it we do it over the course of like a
year um the first time we you know we
learned it's been a 10 year I think it's
been a decade long process from the
first to this and by the end James gun
and I realized the best thing is we do
it like a play instead of watching
anything he he reads all the other
characters and I play rocket and that's
how we do it the first round and it's
really wonderful and then and then then
then as that then after that all gets
laid in then we just you just keep
honing it or working on other things or
improvising um it's very it's it's fun
to improvise off of characters who have
already said something that they can't
change so the rocket can really have a
field day um you like doing it kind of
fun oh I loved it I loved rocket I
absolutely and and this last one I don't
know if you saw it but I I actually
cried like crazy watching it and when we
did it there's a scene where um he loses
his friend and the sound that rocket
makes the only thing that I could even
relate it to is the sound I remember
hearing my own voice when my dad passed
away you know that you hear like there's
something that you hear it and I
remember when we did it in The Sound
Stage I think everybody was sort of like
there was some deep truth to the sound
that came out of my mouth and I think
that's part of why that's a you know I
don't know that really that moment in
that movie is kind of like holy